مريم يمكن ان نقول هناك اخبار عاجله الان
حقيقه الحرس الثوري الايراني هنا في ايران
يؤكد رسميا ما نقله الاعلام الايراني عن
اغتيال اثنين من القاده البارزين في فيلق
القدس في الغاره الاسرائيليه على حي المزه
في دمشق ويقول بانه تم اختيال قائد وحده
الاستخبارات في فيلق القدس العم يوسف اميد
زاده والمشهور بالحاج صادق وكذلك يؤكد بان
الغاره ادت ايضا الى مقتل نائبه في هذه
اللحظات هناك بيان ربما يصدر ل الحرس
وانقل من البيان بشكل مباشر بانه يؤكد ما
تم الحديث عنه في وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه
من ان الغاره الاسرائيليه استهدفت هذا
المبنى السكني في حي المزه وادت الى مقتل
قتل قائدين بارزين في فيلق القدس في الحرس
الثوري في الشق الاستخباراتي
من هذا الحضور
لهذا الفيلق في سوريا وهم العميد يوسف امي
زاده المعروف والمشهور بالعميد الحاج صادق
وكذلك نائب الرجل اللذان كانا متواجدان في
هذا المبنى الذي استهدفته اسرائيل نحن
الان نتحدث عن تاكيد رسمي بيان رسمي للحرس
الثوري يؤكد هذه المعلومات ماذا يعني كل
ذلك مريم يعني بان الحرس الثوري ربما لم
ينتظر اكثر من ساعه فقط ليؤكد هذه
المعلومات وليقول بان هذا الاختيال جرى
بفعل اسرائيلي ومن خلال البيان واضح بان
الحرس الثوري يتبنى لغه مباشره من ان
اسرائيل تدرك تماما بانها ستدفع الثمن على
ما فعلته في هذه الغاره وتدرك بان الحرس
الثور لديه ما يمكن ان يقوم به
سواء في سوريا او في اي منطقه اخرى بحسب
البيان لدى اسرائيل فيها مصالح وحضور
مباشر واضح باننا الان نتحدث عن ضرب في
المنطقه الرماديه بين ايران واسرائيل واضح
بان الهدف وازن حقيقه مريم في هذه الغاره
لم يشر بيان الحرس الثوري الى ما ان
اسرائيل تقوم بالانتقام مث مثلا لما قام
به هو في ضرب الصواريخ البالستيه لما اس
لما اسماه قبل ايام بمقر تجسسي ل الموسات
ولكن المعلومات التي انتشرت هنا في ايران
في وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه وصلت الى حد
بانها تحدثت عن اسماء واظهرت جوازات سفر
احد هؤلاء ما قال الاعلام الايراني بانه
ضابط كبير في المساد يدير عمليات المساد
تحديدا ضد ايران ومحور المقاومه في منطقه
شرق المتوسط هل نحن حقيقه امام مساحه
جديده من الضرب بين ايران واسرائيل خارج
الخطوط الحمراء هذا وارد هل يمكن للحرس
الثوري ربما ان يتحدث عن مبدا الصبر
الاستراتيجي بعد هذه الضربه هذا وارد
ولكنه سيكون هناك تكلفه على الاقل في
مساحات الراي العام في المساحه الشعبيه في
مساحات من يؤيد الحرس ومن يؤيد حضوره في
سوريا في مساحه المحور كله مريم حقيقه
الذي تقوده ايران في المنطقه وتصفه
بمحور المقاومه لماذا نقول هذا الكلام لان
العميد الحاج صادق مصنف اسرائيليا على انه
العدو الاول لها في مساحات الاقليم عندما
نتحدث عن استهداف المصالح الاسرائيليه
عندما نتحدث ربما عن استهداف لبعض القواعد
العسكريه الامريكيه في المنطقه الرجل مهم
الرجل وازن صندوق اسود ربما يتم اليوم
اغتياله اسرائيليا على الاراضي السوريه
اريد ان اذهب قليلا مريم الى الحيز
السياسي الواضح بالنسبه لايران بانها لا
تتصرف بعواطف باحاسيس وبطريقه مغامره او
انفعال عندما نستند الى ما تم سابقا هناك
عمليات اختيال كثيره حقيقه قامت بها
اسرائيل بعض هذه الاغتيالات بحسب
الايرانيين كانت في قلب العاصمه طهران
لاشخاص وازن جدا في النظام الايراني هل
هذا يعني بان ايران ستبقى ربما تتحرك تحت
سقف استراتيجي ترفض فيه الذهاب الى حرب
مفتوحه وتصعيد مفتوح هذا وارد ولكن هل
يعني ذلك بان ايران ستواصل ضربات الظل
ربما يكون ذلك مؤكد حقيقه مريم خاصه وبان
الان نتحدث عن ضرب مباشر لهدف وازن في
الحرس الثوري على الاراضي السوريه هل هذا
الكلام كله يمكن ان ينتهي الى اننا قد
نشهد ربما دخول مباشر لايران في التعاطي
مع اسرائيل في مساحات الاقليم وصولا الى
حرب مفتوحه هذا مستبعد ولكن ما الذي
سيفعله الحرس يقول في بيانه بانه يستطيع
ان يفعل الكثير ا هذا البيان اذا للحرس
الثوري الايراني الذي صدر قبل بضعه دقائق
وكنت تشير عبد القادر الى ما جاء فيه
ونذكر بان هذا البيان للحرس الثوري
الايراني يؤكد اذا اغتيال قائد استخبارات
فيل القدس العميد الحاج صادق ونائبه
بالغارات الاسرائيليه التي استهدفت المبنى
الواقع في المزه بالعاصمه السوريه دمشق
اذا بيان للحرس الثوري الايراني يؤكد
اغتيال مسؤولين في الاستخبارات استخبارات
الحرس الثوري الايراني احدهما قائد وحده
الاستخبارات العميد الحاج صادق بالاضافه
الى ئبه